libre ce qu'on retiendra de marie
trintignant une beauté ténébreuse regard
troublant une voix grave à l'image des
rôles qu'elle a incarné à la télé comme
au cinéma
un parcours alternatif grâce auquel elle
avait su se faire un prénom
elle restera dans nos mémoires notamment
à travers son dernier rôle son dernier
tournage pour france 2 1 incarnez cole
est une femme brillante et passionnée
marie-hélène gonorrhée me passionner son
dernier tournage aura été une affaire de
famille marie a coécrit le scénario avec
sa mère nadine qui réalise également le
film home and calling à son fils de 16
ans interprète bertrand de jouvenel le
jeune amant de colette vincent
trintignant le frère de marie et premier
assistant réalisateur
le dernier rôle de marie trintignant
aura été celui d'une femme libre et
scandaleuse
l'écrivain colette oui c'est quelqu'un
qui n'a qui n'a pas peur de la vie qui
n'a pas peur de repartir à zéro et qui
n'a pas d'appréhension avec la vie
la petite marie voulais être vétérinaire
mais dans cette famille faire du cinéma
c'est héréditaire comme interpréter des
rôles militants en 1999 et les victoires
à la télévision elle défend la lutte des
femmes pour l'avortement
en tant que médecin gynécologue je sais
que les avortements clandestins
l'utilisation des sons des aiguilles à
tricoter diverses plaintes et un réel
danger pour les femmes
le cinéma la télévision c'est le même
métier 10 est elle une affaire de femmes
en 92 de chabrol qui lui confie ensuite
le rôle phare de betty en 1996 ont
commencé en 1996 elle rayonne dans le
cri de la soie rendez-la - shelter je
sais pas ce qui m'a pris une dizaine de
pièces deux surtout aux côtés de son
père conversation sur un quai de gare et
surtout poèmes à lou d'apollinaire jeu
les enfants chéris sh100 la pallée douce
odeur de violette se sentent après midi
pour son premier rôle mari avait quatre
ans c'était mon amour mon amour
réalisé par sa mère